With off canvas,
instead of stacking content vertically,
the off canvas places less frequently
used content, for example navigation or
app menus, off screen, only showing
them if the screen is large enough.
On smaller screens, the off canvas
content is typically shown when
the user taps on the hamburger icon.
Let's take a look and see how it's
done on the web fundamentals site.
In narrow viewport,
the navigation menu is hidden,
until I click the hamburger menu.
In other cases,
the off screen content may actually
come in from off the screen.
In this sample page,
the content is coming in from the left.
But in other cases,
it could come in from the right.
Let's take a look at the code for
this example.
I have two elements, the dark blue nav
and the main content in light blue.
In order to make sure the elements
take up the full viewport width,
I need to set the width on HTML,
body and main to 100 %.
Next, I'll set the styles for
the off-canvas nav element.
I'll set a specific width of 300 pixels,
being careful to keep it
reasonably sized so
that it doesn't overflow the viewport.
I'll use translate minus 300
pixels to move it off the screen.
And add a transition of 0.3 seconds,
so that it animates in nicely.
When I want it to appear, I'll add
an open class that resets the transform.
Now, I'll add a break
point at 600 pixels that
repositions everything
back to its normal spot.
The media query at 600
pixels resets the transform.
Adding flex grow 1 to the main
element allows the element to grow and
take up the full remaining
width of the viewport.
Let's give it a shot in the browser.
When the viewport is small,
the navigation panel is hidden
until I hit the hamburger menu.
But, on wider view port,
it's shown by default.
Nice